are there other reasons for tumor markers to increase other than cancer?
So we don't really know. So remember, tumor markers have a normal range, okay? So let's use
CA153. That's really you typically only found in in breast cancer. I think the range is 0 to 33
or 0 to 35 or something like that. I could be wrong, but that's about the range of CA153. So let's say
yours is 15. Let's say normal range. Well, where's that coming from? So where is that 15 coming from?
And I don't know if it's 15, what, right? In that blood sample that was taken. Yes. So yes,
other cells give off tumor markers. They're not specific to cancer only. So yes, other cells can
give that off. And there's not. And so when they first discover there's a lot of hype about them,
and I've talked about this before, but because they're elevated when somebody does chemotherapy,
then, you know, there's been, you know, the, it's kind of got on the poo poo list for oncologists to
do because then they have to talk people, you know, off the ledge when their tumor markers go up
when they're doing chemotherapy.